s p 500 is a video game in the last
seven trading days from thursday of last
week until today every single day the s
p 500 has hit an all-time high market
opens all-time high market opens
all-time high day of trading all-time
high we live in a video game nothing is
real anymore it doesn't matter if the
fed's gonna taper or not all-time high
whatever the market gets thrown it just
moves right through it and goes to the
all-time high i always say that the
number one way to build a life of wealth
and financial security in the united
states today is that you cannot save
your grandparents told you to save your
parents probably told you to save saving
is a absolute express train to a bad
situation why it's because they are
devaluing the currency when you get a
currency that is being devalued at the
rate at which it is a historic pace
multiple months of over five percent
inflation you are literally losing
purchasing power and so you have to
learn how to invest the s p 500 is
widely considered one of the least risky
ways to actually get exposure to public
equities to american or other companies
now when you start to look at the s p
500 it just goes up this thing literally
over the last year yes there's a couple
of days where it might go down a little
bit but it over any medium to long term
continues to go up this is the last year
and you can see here at the end it's on
an absolute tear seven days in a row
all-time high open the market hit an
all-time high it's a video game now i
have if we go back to the tweet real
quick i have had a secret
friend a secret partner in my s p 500
all-time high journey
at tommy ball game
has every single day that it hits an
all-time high dm'd me the second it's
happened and said spy all-time high and
then i tweet it out it's like a built-in
human personalized alert system every
time smp all-time high bam i tweet
that's why i get it every single time
because tommy ball game now tommy
ballgame isn't just an alert system
though he also did a little bit of
analysis this morning i'm pretty sure
based on his dm that he manually counted
this which is an all-time move
but here's some stats for you
march 23 of 2020 the price bottomed at
218
since that day there have been 411
trading days i really hope he didn't
count each one individually of those 411
trading days the s p 500 has been up had
a day of green 236 times there's been
175 days of red
now on november 5th the price is 470
so if you go back to march 23rd and you
bought at 208
and it's today at 470 it has averaged a
positive 61 cents gain every trading day
since march 23rd 2020. now of course
that would mean that you actually bought
at the absolute bottom on march 23rd so
not everyone did that but there are a
lot of people who bought a little bit
before the bottom and bought afterwards
it didn't matter as long as you
continued to get in the market and not
try to day trade and simply buy or
dollar cost average into the s p 500
over the last year
you have never had more money in that
position because it is at an all-time
high and so what you have to remember is
that you can try to be a genius you can
try to pick stocks you can try to
outsmart the computers and the high
frequency traders on wall street
or you can understand market structure
you can understand that they will not
stop devaluing the currency they may
accelerate or decelerate the pace at
which they do it but they will not stop
devaluing the currency the asset all of
them does not matter if it's public
equities real estate commodities or
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they will
all continue to go up in dollar terms
over very long periods of time because
the currency is being devalued
underneath and so the s p 500 continues
on an absolute tear seven days in a row
that is insane
nothing is real they literally at one
point announced that they were going to
taper some of the bond stuff that
they're doing
and so when we start to look at this you
have to think about if you are sitting
in cash or have a material percent of
your portfolio in cash
why
i don't know what you should go do based
on what your risk tolerance is or what
your financial goals are you have to
decide that for yourself we don't give
financial advice but what i do know is
that if you hold cash you are guaranteed
guaranteed to lose purchasing power
which means it will take more dollars in
the future to buy the exact same assets
so when you look at that s p 500 to see
61 cents of gain on average every day
since march of last year is insane in my
opinion do we like the fact that it
keeps going up like this or are we
nervous
uh i mean
it is what it is like i don't think i
don't know i mean when you look at uh
kind of what's going on in the economy
and the money supply you have to look at
it with everything in context i think
ultimately what we've seen is the price
appreciate rapidly with the money supply
increasing also and not only over the
past year but before that even too when
you look at previous uh i don't have the
charts and savannah but when you look at
previous crashes right the dot-com
bubble the financial crisis et cetera it
took years to recover from this but the
money printing it literally overlays
perfectly with the chart of acceleration
so yeah i mean i mean look at uh just
over the last year alone right we went
from 3 500 on the s p to 47 uh 4700 so
34 up in the last year alone to go along
with a pandemic right a global pandemic
where people were sitting at home and
were not producing goods and services
typically at the rate that they would so
all of this kind of consideration yeah
i'd say it's probably a little
concerning but are people happy about it
i think people that own socks are very
happy about it and that's why we always
preach that the easiest and the best
thing to do is just to get invested
right and then sit back and just let
your money go to work john what do you
think about the s p 500 just hitting
all-time high it's like ringing a bell
just like bang bang bang it's crazy how
many times it has hit an all-time high
um i'm happy about it i have a very very
small percentage of my portfolio in the
s p 500 it i think you should get
exposure to it not financial advice in
any sense of the word um but look when
in doubt zoom out right you can see all
the other crashes in history and
especially 2007's uh probably one of the
main examples we were back to where we
were uh kind of break even in within a
five-year period right and then we saw
exponential growth in that um in the s p
since then so and last year we were back
in what a year we're up 100 a couple
hundred percent look at that i mean when
in doubt zoom out five years you're up
120
um that's insane so the other the other
piece of this that i think is really
important john is that if you go and you
look at five years ago at the uh look at
the rate of growth until 2020 that was
one trajectory but after 2020 we
actually changed the trajectory it got
steeper and so it's accelerating faster
and if this was to continue the five
years starting in march of 2020 is going
to be a much faster growth rate than it
was the five years before there's like
six companies that are
20 i believe 20 around 23 weight of the
s p 500 alone and tesla is now in there
so there's a few things right i think
when you denominate it in bitcoin or
some other kind of asset that it looks a
lot different obviously uh but then two
is like it's accelerating because of
that massive drop-off that we saw within
pandemic started but in my mind that's
the perfect example of uh what's the
saying to be greedy when others are
fearful right yeah the smp
if you literally bought it at the top if
you bought it the day before it crashed
you'd be up a lot this year right so
literally you just need to keep buying
keep investing dollar cost average and
everything's going to be all right
especially when it comes to the s p 500
and other equity markets where we know
the government is just going to continue
to pump stimulus in the economy to make
these things go up so ultimately you
just got to get invested right because
when everyone else was selling when
everyone else was fearful when everyone
else thought kovid was going to destroy
the economy and everything like that the
people that were buying the s p ended up
doing the best if i showed you this
chart and i told you oh by the way
there's 11 million open rolls and
there's uh
more than four and a half percent
unemployment and literally 45 of
americans are doing worse now than they
were a year ago you would be like i'm
confused yeah the missing piece is i got
to tell you oh by the way there's five
and a half percent inflation and it's
been like that for months now all of a
sudden it makes a ton of sense well a
lot of people unfortunately had to sell
their stuff why it was down in that
giant drop because they they were they
were they didn't have cash right they
need all these things uh so it's
important important to have that like
emergency stash of cash just in case uh
but look i mean you got to get invested
great when the price goes down right
look we're not einstein over here but
when the price goes down it's because
there's more sellers than buyers that's
why the price goes down and when they
did a retroactive look this data is a
little bit old because it was from end
of last year they went and they looked
who was selling the most on a percentage
basis of all the age cohorts older
people because what ends up happening is
if you're young if you're 25 years old
in march of 2020 and you've got a couple
of stocks or a little bit of money in
stocks uh and it goes down sure maybe
you buy more maybe you don't but you
have so much left uh time to actually
make it back so if it takes three four
five years it's not a big deal but if
you were right around retirement age or
in retirement and the stock market just
got a 20 haircut you're fearful that
it's gonna take five seven eight years
to come back so what do you do just get
me liquidity and they were just dumping
stock right on they had the highest
percentage basis of all people uh from
the study that i saw that was actually
selling the stocks and so unfortunately
turn around three months later
stock market is absolutely ripping right
right past where it was and now you just
got shaken out of a position and it's
because you don't have a long time
horizon which goes back to if you're a
young person having a ton of time
actually means that you can take more
risk even if it's not the asset you're
selecting all that volatility you can
stomach because you're not worried about
the day-to-day price movements or am i
going to have money in my stock account
to actually be able to eat three months
from now and that's a huge advantage
that usually a lot of people don't talk
about